yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Grand Master brutal force food
Young's and right yep heaven platon here
ever of course I did but not not with
this account so it must be an Aegis I
had played him yeah this is a um rely in
the English not a bad line for black at
all that was super strange move now that
I think of it
yeah we should be for something you can
probably go home yeah and the night on a
four but at least it takes you five I
mean this is not such a bad thing and to
have in plain I would like to get in 95
it's actually quite annoying this
position now for black maybe keeps the
Queen on the border place queen bee
seven yeah that that makes for quite
some sense let's see all right if I've
blunders the house maybe I just demo him
maybe just double okay wait ng5 g5g five
Queenie 394 McQueen is no square it's
unfortunate
so after g5 I have to take and then he
takes on g2 and I'm lost Wow well maybe
I can fight but that was not intended of
course yeah I looked you two hours just
to quickly played yeah mini Esther has
to think about it I can wait after g5
queen is 390 form whoopty seven maybe
rock t 793 will be seven that should
work actually this m93p special piece em
every three no let's work to smoke its
lucky g5 2394 5793 be 793 seven letters
work that's what just just works so
you
go just go like H for knowing let's do
it before g 5 hits again
he takes quite a while yet it's not it's
not easy to play for him I was it was
very lucky I have squatted this really
late and why does that work then wait
yes this is the easiest where I take
this first and this Bishop takes 95 and
here Knight b6 I'm ship f3 might still
hold of course I have Queen takes on h6
that was my original idea
[Music]
there's also stuff like 95 but okay 96
Bishop takes it doesn't do do all that
much
okay no arm and a day for saying not
hanging this
and this isn't all that clear Scott that
22 IDM
you can still click we do too
it's remarkable that that game should be
below where there must have been some
some something something to punish all
that don't know what don't know what
ready time morning check it's just a
pretty pretty meaningless porn
[Music]
grah offered game drawn oh my god I'm
such an idiot am I mean that must have
been completely over there what
everything was hanging in that situation
here like here so how do you have what
is the most convincing one Bishop f6
okay this is just one porn or something
else that who's this is this is not
winning I mean not at all he's he's got
Queen d2 end with opposite colored
bishops there the computer is just far
too high here that that's not just so do
17 it's absolutely nothing because he's
got the default and the opposite colors
bishops will give him the draw very sad
they're very easily so that was was not
good young so this was the best to move
water but is it that leads to the same
thing probably almost him takes takes
and it's
this it is the same thing it is the same
thing that's remarkable we might be six
is very shaky and he was like three
minutes down on the clock it still alone
with that that's really awful yeah g5
net that doesn't work in 1947 this work
it's really disappointing there's such a
huge time advantage and and the loose
position to just have a draw ok guys
thanks for watching